hey bro listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b-25
mitchell Panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and I went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey Ron
Swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell like how did they know who you
are yeah okay um there are these things
called cookies where like if you go to a
site buy something it'll remember you
and then create ads for other stuff you
might want to buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy dude if you think
that's bad go to Google Earth and type
in your address well the police said
they're gonna launch an investigation to
see whether or not I was hacked but it's
very complicated and it could take up to
a month there is nothing more disgusting
than an invasion of privacy and I should
know I've had many women steal my
undershirts I have a press conference
about the Pawnee Commons in two hours so
I need to go through every email that
I've ever sent ever I need to know what
they might use against me you can't hack
into a typewriter that's all I have to
say
can it Unabomber this is an emergency
who or what is penny saver it's a free
circular with a bunch of coupons in it
this was sent to Ron Swanson at Diane's
address where I've lived for less than a
month how is that possible this is an
extreme invasion of privacy the right to
privacy is very important to me my
family has had a single Pio box for
several generations we only ever
subscribed to two magazines Reader's
Digest and ebony ebony was due to a
clerical error but it ended up being an
interesting year of reading I don't know
how this was delivered to me but it
cannot happen again how can I stop it
mmm Donna is great with this sort of
thing she got me off the williams-sonoma
mailing list but then I just signed back
up again
hooked on their oven mitts I need my
mitts on those mitts let me know the
second Donna returns according to her
Twitter feed she got coffee five minutes
ago wait now she's you streaming her
walk back she should be here
in 3 2 1 hey hey hashtag quest for
coffee
rolling up my timeline you get my
snapchat about it no oh there it is
I found this typewriter next to the
courtyard dumpster an old Underwood 5
with original carriage return took her
home polished her up bought a brand new
ribbon off of electronic pay calm okay
somebody's got to do something I'm
getting a cluster headache oh he's
leaving let's go I'm gonna throw it away
no I'm not where's Billy done sir
what is he type in any way if you sons
of [ __ ] try to remove this typewriter
I'll kill you I know rectangle America
megaphone Monday butthole people ought
to have the right to be left alone I
want to get completely off the grid
that's crazy Tom I live for the grid
it's where I meet 40% of my jump-off and
if you're off the grid how are you gonna
post photos of the dope food or
restaurants you're at and all the cool
places you're stunting food is for
eating places are for being end of
discussion
don't leave the grab on the quiz the
best if anything you need to get more on
the grid grid grid grid grid good gravy
how do I get off the grid I will let
both of you go home early no grid no
grid no grid no grid February 2016 I
think you're gonna really enjoy this
month's photo album and includes such
hits as first trip to the dentist
Sonja tries pizza and waterpark vomit
chain reaction why would you take
pictures of that why would you not does
you request it here's a picture of my
son at a recent moment in his life so
cute what are you doing protecting my
son's privacy what I'm just gonna carry
around pictures of my child where anyone
could see them well it's funny you
should mention privacy
because that's our next topic Ron
technically works for grizzle and when
he finds out what grizzle is doing he is
going to lose his mind
I have no reaction to this what I do not
pass judgment on the workings of private
businesses I just build their buildings
and frankly if people are foolish enough
to carry around a doodad that lets
grizzle track their every move this is
what they get but it's illegal I don't
believe that's true
I've spent a fair amount of time with
Grizzles high-priced lawyers and they do
seem to as they say keep it 100 every
year I give Leslie the same present I
give everyone a crisp $20 bill and every
year she gets me something thoughtful
and personal it makes me furious this
year she outdid herself she had it
installed over the weekend so so
beautiful Paul if you ever see another
one of these with my name on it I want
you to drive into the woods and bury it
I don't decide who gets mail sir I just
deliver it passing the buck the last
refuge of the cowardly and black hearted
that seems harsh get out we got rid of
your cell phone this is your last credit
card are you sure you want me to cut up
this card to get you into the parking
garage I'll be taking the bus now and
I'll be paying in cash
what other traces of me exists in the
world think people isn't there photo you
up at JJ's diner from that time when you
oh come on Tom just give me the IP
address of the dude that gave me that
cracked-out yelp review okay here we go
the IP address says it came from someone
inside City Hall in this building oh
hell no well who cares really it's just
some dumb internet person ignore it
ignore it I'm about to come down on this
dude like Thor's hammer Mjolnir I'm
about to bomb Mjolnir on his ass
speaking of bad reviews computers are
mostly pointless but that Yelp thing
gave me a great idea on how to criticize
people in places
I am composing strongly-worded letters
about things I disapprove of and I am
using the Internet to get addresses
where I can send them so far I've
written to a vegetable farm several
European ambassadors a manufacturer of
male Cologne and a nonfat frozen yogurt
bar
dear frozen yogurt you are the celery of
desserts be ice cream or be nothing zero
stars okay all public photos of me
recovered nameplate removed from my
office door pediatrician files
confiscated and destroyed anything I'm
missing great news Ron
jean-ralphio loves you shirt what the
hell are you talking about oh I've been
taking pictures of you all day for my
new facebook album Ron Swan getting off
the grid Tom do you maybe see a problem
with what you've done
I dunno yes sorry
erase erase erase erase all pictures of
Ron what the hell is happening
he accidentally opened a vine just
buying your first selfie Ron and I'm
finding you fine you're something the
world is a nightmare
[Laughter]
erase all pictures of Rana
hey friends I'm just about to go on my
night jog would you like to join me mmm
hard pass we're here because you need to
tend to your woman she's complaining
about everything ruining wine and cheese
club
I literally have 1,000 questions why is
Ron wearing headphones what's when she's
Club and what is he in complaining about
you mostly how you never let her vent
because you're always too busy trying to
solve everything for her she's upset
that I'm trying to help her you've
fallen into a classic trap Christopher
trying to fix a woman's problems instead
of just listening to what they are why
are you yelling Tom put all my records
into this rectangle hey man if Annie's
telling all she can get it herself what
she needs from you is to just look her
in the eyes nod your head and say those
two magic words that sucks that sucks
I spent my entire life reading
instructional books about relationships
in order to trick women into liking me
when Ann tells you what's bothering her
don't try to fix it just say damn yeah
that sucks
the songs just playing one right after
the other this is an excellent rectangle
We Need to Talk what is that this is a
flying robot I just shot out of the sky
after it delivered a package to my house
I thought you didn't like to pass
judgment on the package was addressed to
my son it was four years old and does
not own a grizzled doodad somehow the
robots looked at Diane's computer and
learned something about my child and
then brought him a box of presents
so I destroyed the robot no one is safe
from these bastards tell me what to do
Leslie
I want to help you take them down
you